good morning and welcome to Space Center
Houston I'm William Harris president and
CEO and I'm so delighted to welcome you
here for this extraordinary presentation
you're here during a very special week
at Space Center Houston it is our moon
to Mars Festival presented by Welby
Financial
the festival runs through Sunday so we
hope you'll enjoy it uh while you're
here today and we invite you to be part
of this very very and special
celebration recognizing our preparation
to return to the moon and eventually
send humans onto Mars and we're very
excited that you're here for this
special presentation of NASA presents
the Artemis 3 lunar spacesuit
public event revealing the Artemis 3
lunar spacesuit thank you to our NASA
and Axiom space colleagues for selecting
us as your host
today's program is being streamed live
on NASA TV and so I want to extend a
warm welcome to all of our online
viewers
and we have some very special students
from Space Center Houston's Explorer
camps who are joining us today would you
please all stand
and please stay standing and then I also
want to recognize our participants in
our girls STEM Academy would you all
stand as well
[Applause]
you are all the next generation of
explorers you'll have many opportunities
in your career and your life choices
from an astronaut to an artist or a
scientist or an engineer you can do it
and everyone plays a vital role in
advancing space exploration so again
let's get them all a round of applause
you all can be seated thank you for
joining us this morning you're part of
living history
now I'd like to introduce our speakers
we're honored to be joined by Bob Cabana
NASA associate administrator
[Applause]
Lara Kearney Eva and human surforce
Mobility Program manager at NASA Johnson
Space Center and a member of our board
of directors
[Applause]
Vanessa wise center director for NASA
Johnson Space Center
[Applause]
Michael sufordini president and CEO of
Axiom space
[Applause]
Mark Greely Eva program manager of Axiom
space
and Russell Ralston Eva program Deputy
manager of Axiom space
[Applause]
and now gives me great pleasure to turn
the podium over to Bob Cabana
thank you William and thank you to Space
Center Houston for hosting this event
today it's really great to be here with
Axiom for this event Mike
you know when I look back on the Apollo
program when all of us look back we look
at those iconic images of the technology
that enabled the astronauts to make
those first steps on the moon their
space suit
and now we're developing a spacesuit for
a new generation the Artemis Generation
The Generation that's going to take us
back to the moon and on to Mars and it
is going to be so exciting
when that first woman steps down on the
surface of the Moon on Artemis 3 she's
going to be wearing an axiom spacesuit
so we're gonna
and and I can't wait to see that happen
you know we're going back to the moon
but we're going to the South Pole of the
moon this time and why are we going
there it's challenging right we're going
to learn more there's water ice there
water is hydrogen for fuel and oxygen to
breathe we are going to learn how to
operate on the moon for extended periods
of time and learn how to operate away
from planet Earth and utilize the
resources on the moon and all of this is
in preparation for eventually going on
to Mars and we're making those first
steps now we've got to have an EBA
Mobility suit in order to make that
happen and this is a suit that's going
to do it
you know I'm very pleased to be here at
the Johnson Space Center this was home
to me for a very long time and one of
the Prides of the Johnson Space Center
is the Eva surface Mobility Program
that's here and it's my pleasure Now to
turn this over to the director of the
Johnson Space Center Vanessa ice Vanessa
[Applause]
thank you Bob
so at NASA's Johnson Space Center we're
just so super proud to be able to
continue the legacy of doing space walks
as Bob mentioned from Apollo Heritage
using our suits for science operations
assembly of the International Space
Station
and operations and maintenance that's
ongoing and now we're looking forward
for our return to the moon and using our
suits for doing science operations on
the lunar surface at Johnson Space
Center we have been working doing
technology development in-house with our
engineers and our operators on design
for an exploration suit we have provided
all of that technology all of the
drawings all of the data all of the test
results for the community and Axiom
space will be one of the companies that
is going to take that and make us new
suits we have not had a new suit since
the suits that we designed for the space
shuttle and those suits are currently in
use on the space station so 40 years
we've been using the same suit based on
that technology and now today Axiom is
going to to innovate they're going to
take what NASA has provided in from the
testing that we've done and they will
now take and come up with more
functionality more performance more
capability and we're very excited about
what's going to be happening at nicest
Johnson Space Center we are proud to
partner we will be working together
we'll provide our expertise we're going
to provide all of our facilities and we
will be working together to make sure
that we have a safe suit that performs
and does everything that our astronauts
need for doing surface operations so
we're looking forward to the things that
Axiom is doing and I want to thank the
Axiom team I want to thank the NASA and
all of our teams that work together to
make this happen thank you
and now I'm going to turn it over to
Lara
hi good morning glad to be here and to
see you guys today I am truly honored to
be the manager of what Vanessa mentioned
is the Eva and Human Service Mobility
Program here at Johnson Space Center
that for short means spacesuits and
Rovers The spacesuits are the first part
of our program that is becoming real
we've been working really hard for a few
years to get everything on contract but
once that is in place and we actually
have contractor selected it's really
excited to see their work coming to
fruition and seeing real Hardware so
this contract is a little bit different
it's similar to what we have used for
commercial cargo and Commercial crew
where we call it a service contract so
historically NASA has actually owned the
spacesuits think of it like owning your
car the way we have contracted on what
we call the extra vehicular activity
Services contract is we actually buy
services from the vendor so think of it
more like a rental car so Axiom will be
providing the hardware for both training
and for flight they will bring that
Hardware in and we NASA will utilize it
and operate it on the surface of the
Moon for our moon walking so NASA will
actually be in the role still of Mission
Control and making the mission Authority
Mission execution decisions but axiom's
going to be right there with us making
sure that suit is as safe as we have our
astronauts walking on the surface of the
Moon
so the suit we have a lot of tough
requirements on it so these guys have
their work cut out for them the Moon is
definitely a hostile place and the South
Pole is going to really be a challenge
so a lot of thermal requirements we are
really looking for improved Mobility so
that our astronauts can operate more
efficiently and effectively than they
were able to do many years ago when
Apollo and then of course we have really
stringent safety requirements as Vanessa
mentioned on the suits as well so they
certainly have their cut work cut out
for them but we are absolutely confident
that they are going to be successful
uh so our role as NASA is as Vanessa
said to make sure that all of our
expertise and our data and our
facilities are made available to them
and um then we will be in there
um hand in hand with them helping make
sure that they are successful bringing
all of our knowledge to the table all of
our experience along with our our
friends from the crew office just
providing them our expertise and advice
and guidance as they go forward so super
excited to have Mark and Russell and
their team and really looking forward to
a few years from now when we see that
first Axiom boot print on the moon
thank you
all right we keep forgetting to
introduce so I think I'm going to pass
it on to Mr Mike sephardini
all right
thank you Laura and Bob and Vanessa too
for being here this is a big deal for us
let me start by saying uh Mark when I
look at here this sea of new astronauts
I think we're going to need some more
suits
but first let me let me tell you how
pleased we are as a company it's a it's
a huge deal to be selected to provide
the the lunar surface suit for NASA's
Artemis program it's a it's an
international program we're not just
taking the nation to the moon and Beyond
we're taking the the we're taking
civilization to the moon and Beyond and
so we're pleased that Humanity's next
steps on the moon are going to be in an
axiom space suit and we're very excited
to be a part of this uh the exploration
Mission as it goes forward
the other thing I need to say is uh and
they've they've touched on a little bit
here this morning but this is not
something that you do by yourself this
is a partnership it's a partnership with
NASA the design that we chose and
brought forward is a evolvable design
from the orbit suit to the lunar surface
suit it's based on about 10 years worth
of work that that's been going on at
NASA Johnson Space Center by suit
experts
um and we're we're happy to have all of
that expertise uh and that work done I
think I think when it's all said and
done about 50 of the suit will be based
on the original design done by NASA
probably the other 50 will be the work
uh that this team sitting in the
auditorium will do so that's first and
very very important and as Laura said
this is a critical system it's like uh
you know we all get nervous along lunch
day well when you do an Eva it's it's uh
it's a significant Challenge and so it's
very important that you have very strict
safety guidelines and a suit that will
provide their redundancy and the
reliability you need to make sure every
time a human steps foot on the Moon that
they'll be able to do if they need to
safely and get back and be ready for the
next uh the next mission
so for a second though I want to I want
to take a moment to acknowledge the
Axiom team which is as far as I can tell
nobody's working on suit today because
they're all here
but could you guys stand up and be
recognized this is the action space team
you guys are awesome
um and and when I say Axiom team it's
not just Axiom space KBR Paragon David
Clark uh let's see apt research sophic
and the aerosciences and technology did
I get them all
and airlock oh goodness gracious airlock
the
uh I did I mention didn't mention
paragraphs I got left out I am too all
right
sorry about that Paragon intuitive
machines and airlock
um anyway my point is we're a big team
we're we've brought a lot of expertise
from around the country to work together
to build this suit and it's a critical
part of exploration uh and we're we're
extremely excited and proud to been
selected to uh to go on this journey
with uh with NASA's it takes uh
civilization beyond beyond low earth
orbit so with that I think my job is to
hand it off to Mark and we've been
sitting here talking about all this
stuff but we have an exciting thing to
show you so Marco get us started down
the road go ahead thank you Mike yeah so
a lot of hard work has has been
completed for the team to be here today
with the space suit for the last couple
of years our team's been off really
focused on on three things people
processes and facilities and Equipment
our our team is comprised of many many
people from the NASA xcmu program so
they bring a lot of expertise forward a
lot of our team has worked multiple Eva
programs and then we leveraged industry
automotive
oil and gas the Theater Arts and and
even
design
design from some of the the uh I'm sorry
I lost my words
uh no our
sorry
professional clothing design thank you
so our we have a vast base a really
talented and experienced people
um
our processes you combine all that with
axiom's Agile development process and
the team's able to move extremely fast
but but in a very very
in a very
uh
in a very controlled environment which
is critical to to building and designing
space flight Hardware
you couple that with using NASA's xcmu
Technologies and and it just makes the
team's performance even greater for for
success
Axiom has a number of facilities the the
most recent facility we're about we have
just populated or moved into is the Eva
program facility so team is very excited
about that we vertically integrate
integrated all the team members and
Axiom Under One Roof
and we're about to open our
state-of-the-art Labs we've been working
in temporary space space which which has
been very accommodating
um but we'll have everything we need to
design manufacture spacesuits for the
lunar surface and for axiom's space
station and with that I just want to
thank the Eva team on behalf of Russell
and I thank you so much for for all of
your hard work we thank your families
for standing standing by as as as the
teams work long hours sometimes and we'd
also like to thank Laura Chris Jesse Ben
we appreciate all the collaboration with
you and your team the insight and
collaboration has been has gone
exceptionally well and and you guys are
a big part of our success as well thank
you
I
I think we're going to a video now
right now
the Susan areas today were developed
several decades ago originally they were
developed for the space shuttle and
they're using the International Space
Station today but if we want to go back
to the Moon then we need a new space too
space new design has been really
evolutionary for a decade and we're kind
of taking a larger lean we are changing
it so it was dust tolerant so that you
can walk far distances that you can help
if your fellow crew member is incapacity
and the ability to bring them back with
you so all these updates were more of a
revolution than an evolution of a
different design but I'm excited by some
of the really new developments in
technology that have been added in and I
think it's going to be a great suit
it is an unbelievable amount of effort
from seamstresses to requirement
Specialists to Engineers managers we
have a range of skill sets and everyone
is so proud to be doing what they're
doing it's like a little bit of each of
us is going up there with the astronauts
and a little bit of our mentors a little
bit of our family like it's it's more
than
just ourselves right it's everyone
before us and everyone after us so
that's um you can definitely feel it
that gives you Goosebumps right like
that is it hasn't sunk in yet and I
don't know if it will ever sink in even
when it's happening and you're looking
at the moon and you're like there's
someone on the moon in an axiom suit
like
that is the dream
[Music]
thank you
space is changing so fast right now and
it's going to be such a great time to
want to get into any aspect of the Space
Program whether you know as an engineer
a designer an astronaut somebody you
know stepping foot on another planet
and now the moment you've all been
waiting for
foreign
[Applause]
good morning
my name is Russell Ralston I'm the
deputy program manager of VBA at action
space in the suit here this morning is
Jim Stein Jim is an extraordinary
engineer he's a chief engineer on our
team so we gave him the honors yeah yeah
go ahead
we gave Jim the honors of demonstrating
the suit this morning I'm going to give
him this uh this little walking sap here
we are in Earth gravity we're not on the
moon if anybody doesn't know on the moon
the gravity is about 1 6 of what it is
here so just in case Jim loses his
balance safety reasons want him to have
that but so I'm going to talk through
the suit design just very briefly and as
I do that Jim's going to perform some
different actions Mobility to
demonstrate the mobility of the suit uh
before we before we get into that though
I want to talk about this cover layer so
the cover layer that you see the black
the orange the blue personally I think
this looks amazing I want to thank
Esther Marquis for helping us design
this Esther is a designer a spacesuit
designer on the show For All Mankind if
anyone has seen that on Apple TV plus so
so this suit has a lot of that worked
into this one of the differences between
this suit and the suit that will be on
the moon is that it will the moon suit
will mostly be white so we'll replace
all the black with white and that's
really for thermal reasons so didn't
want anybody to to get that mixed up but
other than that I think this is just a
fantastic fantastic looking suit so let
me let me go top to bottom here and just
describe the suit overall so we'll start
with the light band I think you guys saw
the lights as Jim walked out on stage uh
on the light bound is mounted to the
visor assembly into the helmet bubble
and this this essentially gives the
astronauts lights to see where they're
in shaded portions of the moon or if
they're in low earth orbit in a night
pass they can turn on these lights to
see using tools or translating on the
space station or anything like that we
also have on the side here we have a HD
video camera so those of us back on
spaceship earth watching the Eva will be
able to watch it in high definition
which will be a fantastic upgrade I
think from from current day technology
all of this is mounted on the helmet
bubble which is amounted to what we call
in this configuration of our suit the
hard upper torso so the hard upper torso
goes roughly from Jim's waist up to the
top and this is kind of the core
structure of the suit it's what we
attach everything to so the arms I'll
talk about the backpack in a minute so
yeah if Jim wants to demonstrate some of
the arm ability here this really just
provides us again some structured amount
thanks to
each of the arms have a variety of
Mobility joints and elements that we've
designed at Axiom including the gloves
the gloves are a critical part of the
suit design especially for microgravity
Evas where you're using them for hours
at a time to translate to operate tools
to you know fix things to the suit and
so on so we put a ton of effort into
those gloves pretty pretty proud of
where they're at and are confident those
are going to perform very well if Jim
turns to the side here
some people may be wondering hey how do
you even get in this suit there's a
hatch on the back actually you can see
two hinges here so this suit's a little
bit different than the suits of kind of
today that's used on the space station
this is called a rear entry design or a
back entry Design This hatch would open
up you would put your feet in put your
arms in and then kind of shimmy down
into the suit and then we would close
the hatch
um mounted to the hatch is this box
affectionately known as the backpack we
call it the the portable life support
system so inside of this box are all the
parts and the components to keep to kind
of keep you alive while you're doing Eva
you can think of it as like a very fancy
scuba tank and air conditioner kind of
combined into one so on the lower torso
so let's start kind of from the waist
going down to the to the boots I'll let
Jim do some squats and lunges and and
just show off some of the some of the
mobility uh that the suit has some
demonstration different movements
there's a variety of joints that we've
put as well into the lower torso
assembly and this is going to be a huge
improvement over the Apollo suits the
Apollo suits didn't have many of these
types of joints that we've put in this
suit so the astronauts will be more
comfortable have an easier time walking
performing tasks getting down to like to
pick up a rock or something like that or
use a geology tool
um and then the other thing that uh yeah
that's a great great demonstration there
about my gym
um the other thing I wanted to touch on
is the boots the boots are critical uh
critical part of the suit especially for
the the Artemis 3 mission and missions
to the the South Pole of the Moon we'll
be entering regions called permanently
shadowed regions these are regions of
the Moon that never see sunlight and
they're very very cold and so it's very
important that we insulate the boots
appropriately to keep the astronauts
feet
comfortable during the Eva that's a
portion of the design there's there's as
Mr suffragini mentioned there's many
portions of this design that we've that
we've kind of adopted from xcmu and are
continuing to refine that's that's an
excellent portion the xcmu team did a
tremendous job and a lot of our
teammates did a tremendous job designing
those boots so we're taking those
forward and refining them to flight
those are really a key aspect of the
suit
um
I think I've covered everything pretty
quickly here at a high level I don't
think I've missed anything here so I
know we've got some questions and
answers that we want to go to but before
we do that I'd love to introduce our
director of human space flight and the
upcoming commander of ax2 mission to the
International Space Station Peggy
Whitson Peggy has spent a lot of time in
spacesuits
foreign
[Applause]
example of what Innovation can do it's
this is going to be such a much more
flexible suit and the range of motion is
really going to improve the astronauts
ability to do all those tasks that
they're going to do while they're out
exploring on the lunar surface and
eventually on Mars that would be so
special and we are here today actually
because of this young group of people
here that are here for the Moon to Mars
Festival we think that it's really
important that we get you guys started
on your space flight training and it's
it's really important because we know
that you're going to be our future and
you're going to be able to wear this
suit someday so we're very much looking
forward to that and we actually have
some really little special guests that
are going to ask some questions and I
have somebody I'd like to introduce
who's going to help us out with that
this is my pilot John schoffner we're
flying
we're flying on the Axiom 2 mission
that's going to the International Space
Station in a few months and John is here
to help me out and get some young people
up here to to chat with you and ask a
few questions about this suit
here we go well I have the extreme
pleasure of talking to myself in the
past I was I had an astronaut in me
since I was 10. it took me a while but
because of today the worst been the
weight has been worth it to talk to some
people today first I'd like to thank
NASA and Axiom for making all of this
possible in the private and commercial
space flight Endeavor I think it's a
great step and we're going to introduce
some kids to you that I think will be
your future both for Axiom Artemis and
NASA so
I'd like to bring these young people
down here that have brought us some
really fabulous questions
by the way thank you Peggy I look
forward to our flight
first
looking good
come on over here
you know this is great for me this is
actually my demographic so I I feel
right at home all right
awesome so what do you think that's
quite a suit right
pretty neat huh
good now I understand you guys have some
questions
uh Remington you're eight years old
you've been thinking about space for how
long
okay so what is your question today
do you wear your space suit in space
oh that you're you're is that question
for me
I'll take it uh well I won't actually
wear this suit I might sneak back
tonight and slip it on we'll see what
happens but uh I think this suit will
look great on you so I'm looking forward
to one day seeing you in space in this
very suit would you like that
cool
good morning
you're Ian right
okay how old are you
um I'm five
that's awesome so you have a question
for Russell and Russell's right back
here behind us
what is your question for Russell
um what's your favorite part about your
spacesuit oh that's a that's a great
question
um you know if you're if you're gonna
walk on the moon I think you have to do
it in some pretty cool shoes so probably
the boots I think the boots are probably
my favorite part he likes the boots I
like your shoes by the way today
thank you for your question Ian
you look good in this suit also
hi Charlotte
I met you a minute ago up there
you you had a lot more to say then
so you have a question I think it's for
Peggy right
you want me to help you you know I know
she she makes me nervous too
she's she's my commander and she's very
famous astronaut and it's okay she has
answers for everything I've tried so I
think your question is
how far away is the Earth from Mars is
that what you'd like to know
um I don't know
you don't know okay that's okay I don't
either but Peggy knows I think it's a
120.22 Million Miles Away
that takes a long time to get there
maybe like almost nine months but I'd
sign up so
how far does your grandmother live away
thank you for your question this morning
viz
good morning sir
10 years old
you're almost going to be 11 though
right all right okay for Mark
okay Mark is right back here the
gentleman that introduced the suit to
you okay what is your question
what what characteristics about the suit
will help us survive in space
that's a great question Vis so as you
probably already know deep space can be
a very harsh environment
so and there's no Oxygen there's no
atmosphere so when we design our suit we
have to make sure it can keep you warm
it can cool you there's oxygen for you
to breathe and even food and water so
those are all very important aspects of
of our new spacesuit
all right you've got it from the top
thank you uh Remington back to you
you had another question this one I
think is for Russell was that right
I'll take it okay uh
okay we're working on it we're almost
there
how long can you live in space how long
can you live in space that's a that's a
great question so we've had people or
NASA has had people as an agency on this
International Space Station for over 20
years some of those individuals have
have stayed on the space station for
over a year at a time but we don't
actually know how long so we need to
keep exploring need to keep building
space stations and going back to space
to figure out answers to questions just
like that
thank you
that's long enough for me
great job thank you uh Jane over to you
in the pink
okay you have a question for Peggy
I have questions for her too but how
about you first
what is your question
friends can you go on a space mission as
an astronaut
I've been on three different space
flights previously they were long
duration missions and John and I are
going to go on another mission together
here shortly in a few months and so
that'll be four but I'm looking forward
to any others I can get
[Laughter]
how many times would you like to go to
space
three
okay we've got you down for that got you
down for three okay
this last question is yours are you
ready
yes okay this is for Bob right behind
you Bob Cabana and Mike suffradini but
these two gentlemen here what is your
question what
when will we see the spacesuit on the
moon
that is a great question Vince and NASA
is working very very hard to ensure that
we keep Artemis 3 on track and our goal
is to have the first woman and next man
back on the surface of the Moon on
Artemis 3 in 2025.
and they'll be wearing an axiom lunar
surface suit
[Applause]
[Music]
in 2025 when the suit is on the moon uh
when well yes
how old will you be
11 13. okay 13. awesome uh the Artemis
generation thank you very much and we'll
see you guys in class
[Applause]
thanks for coming up sweetie
thank you
wow wow that is super cool isn't it
exciting let's do another round of
applause for everyone this is so
exciting to be part of this
[Applause]
well again I want to express heartfelt
thanks to all of our panelists here
congratulations to NASA and Axiom for
this amazing Milestone and achievement
as we prepare to return humans to the
Moon in a entirely new architecture and
program and we can't wait for that day
when we have the first woman a person of
color and other astronauts step on the
surface of the Moon and really begin a
whole new phase of Adventure and Science
and exploration so with that that
concludes today's program thank you for
joining us and I would like to invite
members of the media to come to the
front for a closer conversation and we
look forward to having all of you join
us at the Moon to Mars Festival here at
Space Center Houston again it runs
through Sunday of this week with live
entertainment on Thursday Friday and
Saturday night and Sunday afternoon
again thank you for joining us
thank you